hey 42 here inside your skull is about
one and a half kilos of meat that
somehow manages to keep you breathing
help you remember where your wallet is
and remember which is the best hole to
put your luncheon no no not that one and
you know what master societ normally
does a pretty decent job of stuff but
when you are dealing with something so
unbelievably complicated among the
billions of humans all over the planet
you're occasionally going to have some
pretty unusual brain anomalies there's
the obvious ones like amnesia and
dyslexia but today we're looking at
naughty neurons peculiar pathways and
confusing consciousness we're looking at
six bizarre brain disorders Rylee day
sounds like an awful 90s pop star but
it's actually a genetic condition
officially named for merely a
dysautonomia which has a notable effect
of making people unable to feel pain but
if you're wondering okay where is this
race of super people well it also causes
poor growth unstable blood pressure
violent vomiting pneumonia and problems
with speech and movement so whilst I'm
sure they'd love to help save you from a
burning building they kind of have their
own issues to deal with it's also very
unique to one group of people the only
ever cases of rarely Day syndrome have
been found in Ashkenazi Jews the Jewish
people are for the most part split into
three ethnic groups Ashkenazi Sephardic
and Mizrachi Ashkenazi is the biggest
group originally from Eastern Europe
containing about 11 million people half
of which live in the u.s. to really rub
it in sufferers also don't produce any
tears there's also an opposite condition
hyperalgesia which is a hypersensitivity
to pain this one's not genetic though it
can be caused by long-term opiate use
like of heroin addiction next we have
Alice in Wonderland syndrome
what do you think this is do you go
chasing rabbits do you see smiling cuts
wherever you go no in this Wonderland
you lose control of your perception of
size and things seem all out of
proportion like your Alice eating the
cake and drinking from the bottle
growing and shrinking the medical terms
are micropsia and macros eeeh not seeing
things as small and seeing them as big
or you can get Pell op seer and tele op
SIA where objects seemed nearer or
further away unsurprisingly this can
happen through taking hallucinogenic
drugs but it also affects those with
severe migraines and brain tumors many
children experience a form of it at some
point but it disappears in teenage years
it's also one of the symptoms of the
epstein-barr virus which is a type of
herpes interestingly Lewis Carroll was
known to suffer from migraines so
perhaps this was his inspiration for the
distorted world down the rabbit hole I
don't want to know how he got the idea
of an extremely high caterpillar though
the Cheshire Cat once said if you do not
know where you want to go it doesn't
matter which path you take and this
leads us to our next condition abbulu
mania this is what we call pathological
indecisiveness a lot of people say
they're bad at making decisions I might
spend 10 minutes knowing and their
fingernails as that item from chocolate
cake to cheese cake obviously is going
to be chocolate cake you idiot but this
is much worse than that decision-making
involves various parts of the brain and
varies depending on the type of choice
for example it's a different process for
a free choice such as what's your
favorite sandwich compared to a closed
choice such as beer or cider with abbulu
mania the software is massively
overanalyzed the options always thinking
of the worst outcomes and so managed to
talk themselves out of ever doing
anything effectively becoming socially
paralyzed now let's talk some selves
there's also bit understanding about the
senses for example the idea that there
are only five of them what about the
sense of balance of pain and
proprioception which is an understanding
of the relative positions of your body
parts
synesthesia is a condition where
perceptions that are normally separate
become mixed such as seeing numbers as
colors or tasting words there are many
different forms but the number color
thing is the most common affecting
yellow out of purple people with the
condition some of the rarer forms of the
condition includes seeing time as shapes
and feeling over people sensations like
if you saw someone scratching their leg
you would immediately feel the same
scratching on your own by it's like a
hyper form of empathy the list of famous
synesthetes is they're called include
Pharrell Williams
Tesla and kadinsky prosopagnosia is an
impairment of your facial recognition
abilities controlled by the fusiform
gyrus in your frontal lobe
it can even resort to not being able to
recognize your own face which means you
can play Where's Wally with your own
family album a common issue that most of
us have is a difficulty telling apart
people of different races and it seems
that it's not that we can't tell the
difference it's just that we don't
psychologist Daniel Levin puts it like
this when a white person looks at
another white person's nose they're
likely to think to themselves that's
John's nose when they look at a black
person's nose they're likely to think
that's a black nose for your own race
you look in a holistic way getting an
overall impression of it whereas with
other races you just bounce around the
features like you've not seen a face
before and you're trying to understand
what it is it's simply because your
brain is less used to seeing faces of
other races than of your own obviously
this improves dramatically if you live
in a multicultural area but for those
who prosopagnosia there's no real way to
improve their facial recognition
abilities so they have to rely on
remembering people's dress sense or body
language in order to distinguish between
them not recognizing your own face is
one thing but what about not knowing who
is in charge of your own hunt alien hand
syndrome was first documented in Germany
in 1908 and has since been most commonly
associated with people who've had their
two hemispheres of their brain
surgically set
rated often is a cure for epilepsy but
it can also occur after various brain
conditions like Alzheimer's tumors and
so on with alien hand syndrome one hand
moved purposefully seemingly of its own
will and the owner of the hand can do
nothing to stop it no matter how hard
they try now if there's any bosses
watching who've had a sexual harassment
allegation made against you don't try to
use alien hand syndrome as an excuse
you're just a creep and you deserve to
be fired the brain is unbelievably
complicated and we never know what a
usual brain syndrome will manifest
itself out of the blue so if you're
worried that you'll never stop smoking
weed in your bedroom playing call of
duty and skipping on the housework maybe
just keep sticking it out until the
world finally recognizes your faulty
motivational syndrome and you might get
the sympathy you richly deserve thanks
for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2 do you worry about a zombie
uprising well fear not the US Department
of Defense has you covered the Pentagon
has created a comprehensive plan
detailing how to counter a zombie
apocalypse herring or quite simply the
undisputed Nobel Prize winners of
underwater communication because they
use farts to talk to each other